美國眾議院議長裴洛西在昨天8月2號晚上抵達台灣
全球股市是馬上大漲
既然很有波動我們當充交易者就可以從中有很多獲利的機會
那我們就來復盤一下昨天晚上一個純看價量的當充交易者會怎麼樣打這個盤
這是一個實戰復盤的影片
那我們就從這個每股開盤時間是9點半嘛
我們就從這個9點出頭開始復盤好了
那原本裴护西就有一些可能會抵達台灣的聲音
但是股市還是有一些不確定性的
所以日盤是跌了蠻多
然後第一根出現的這個爆大量是在9.09
那在這個時候這個收K的時候我們就會怎麼設定
我們就會設定在這個低點610跌破空單進場
然後在下一根仍然是爆大量後的同方向接續爆大量
所以會把610的這個出價空單取消改成這個628的出價空單
大家自己一直看著這個查價
然後又再到了下一根仍然是非常有量的
所以就在這個轉移到630的出價空單
就是空點就持續的上移
那這樣子追蹤的好處就是你的停損
都是停損在最高點加一個Tick
創新高的時候
那這樣就是你一直不停的移動你的空點
所以你的空點就會越來越高
而且你的停損仍然不會很長
然後
好 然後
在這邊這個
630的空單就吃到了出價進場
那停損的話就是創新高
所以是在641+1的642停損
然後630進場嘛
所以停損是12點
然後停力就是24點
所以是630-24的606停力或642停損
然後
然後因為是創新高
所以就算到ER的時候
那個出價的停損單也不需要移動到寶本的位置
然後
然後這邊就穿架了嘛
就過606
所以這一單就成功獲利24點
然後這邊就重新變空手
然後又馬上出現了下一個暴打量
那一樣
在這邊就是設615的出價空單
然後到這邊就把615出價空單取消掉
在這邊變成627就是低點減易的出價空單
而我就不詳細講策略了
那個前面的影片講過很多次了
就是直接講復盤
那如果你不知道基本策略是什麼的話
就去看前面的影片
然後這邊627就跌破了
啊
出價了嘛
628跌破
所以這邊627空單進場
那停損一樣是高點加1
所以是640
那這個risk是13點
所以就是627減26
就是601停利或640停損
然後這邊非常的運氣不好
601沒有打到
然後
好
還是差一點到這邊
601還是沒有打到
然後就重新打到627了
那因為這邊不是最高點嘛
不是在創新高停損
所以這一單是會保本的
那因為這個的高點比這個高嘛
好
所以這一單是保本出場
就是
這個平價位
627進
然後627出
然後
OK
然後這邊又出現了一個新的爆大量
所以這邊是
呃
設定629的出價空單
然後629
出價取消
這邊改成636的出價空單
然後就吃到進場
停損一樣是649
就是進場之後馬上去設定停損
好這件事我講過很多次了
進場的第一件事情
你看到那個單
你滑鼠就直接放在那個
MIT的設定的那個數字
一進場瞬間馬上設定停損
好嗎
這個非常重要
因為它有可能
你一進場之後
突然往上爆噴一根嘛
那或者是
突然往下爆噴一根
這都有可能
你進了一個多單
的瞬間
裴頭期如果突然中槍
啪
直接往下噴一百點
這個都是有可能發生的嘛
所以
一進場瞬間馬上掛停損
這個真的很重要
真的很重要
所以我花了蠻多秒數來講
好
所以這邊是一個636的空單
然後
636空
高點是648
所以648+1
所以Risk是13
那636扣
扣13乘2是610
然後
這個是最高點
所以是不會開寶本的
就是比剛才的那個高點更高
所以這個是創新高的地方停損
就不需要開寶本
然後
這邊610又穿架了
所以這一單又再賺到26點
拿到這邊
就已經累積獲利到50點了
然後
然後這邊這個是
爆大量的黑K嘛
所以是掌過做多
所以是619
設定619的出價多單
那這邊就達到了
然後619的多單
停損是
所以Risk是11
那
因為它不是最低點
所以到620的時候
欸不對
到630的時候
就會把這個
停損出場的地方
的608取消
改掛到619
就是進場的地方
然後下一根K棒就被打到619了
所以這邊就被寶本出場
所以這邊就被保本出場
那所以這單是
平倉損益是0
那當然會虧一點的
就是價值一點的手續費
所以我的手續費加稅
所以是略低於1點
不過我們就用1點來估計
沒有關係
然後再等待下一個400口
喔這邊有一個400口
然後這個是
呃
漲過了嘛
喔
這個是6
好這個是607的多單
高點加1嘛
然後
欸
607的多單
然後低點是
所以
Risk是
15點
因為停損是592
607到592是15嘛
然後607再加
15的兩倍30
所以是
592停損或637停利
然後
這邊最高點是631
沒有穿架
還沒到
快停利了
好
然後
最後沒有停利到
而且
喔這邊講一下
在出現了這個紅K的時候
我們就會設定它的低點疊破
然後掛兩倍的NIT
例如說你是打
兩口大台
那你就掛4口大台的出價
那如果是5口大台
你就掛10口大台的出價空單
那在這邊就打到這個出價空單
所以這是一個
607進場的多單
然後在這個地方
這個
兩倍出價
607的空單
所以這一單
剛好也是平價位進出
但是
不是保本
是
剛好
反向的進場點
在同一個數字而已
然後
好
然後這個
停利點是在37
然後最高點是33
差了4點
不過這就是
運氣運氣
OK
那也沒什麼好說的
然後這個空單進場之後
就是
停損點是這個
618+1的619
那因為這也是一個暴打量
所以
一樣會掛兩倍的出價多單
就是
打到的話就是兩倍的反向
好
然後這邊打到了
所以是619的兩倍多單
然後
OK
然後這邊又是
暴打量
所以這邊
下面是
低點是623
所以
這邊會掛一個兩倍的
622的出價空單
然後
馬上就又知道了
所以
我們的
619的多單
又馬上翻空
變成
這個
這個低點-1的
622的空單
就是
多空
這邊
就是多
多單又馬上又翻成空單
變成
2倍-622的
的
空單
然後
停損是在這個
+1
Tick的
然後
好
然後這邊就停損了
那這個
這個地方
是這個
裴洛西飛機降落的時候啦
就是本來這邊剛好是多單啊
但是因為這邊有個暴打量被跌破了
然後
這個
這個時間點
裴洛西的
這個
扳機
確定
抵達台灣降落
然後就
全球的股市是都噴上去
當然
台股是跟隨美股的嘛
所以美股就是噴上去
然後
這邊直接噴了一個
六百口
再噴了一個一千口
所以
這個停損一定要馬上射啦
你有可能
說不定
你一進場
然後下一根就噴出去
這個都是有可能的
然後
從這個起漲點
630附近
直接爆噴
然後有一根
有一根
這個
呃
一直這樣上去上去
你每一根K棒
你都是設低點減1空單
然後取消低點減1空單
取消低點減1空單
就是一直移動去追蹤它
那
這邊疊破
就會進空單
然後
因為下一根是大量
黑K嘛
所以
現在變成掛兩邊
1空單或
679多單
就是
基本上兩邊突破啊
這就是一個大量區
兩邊突破你都會進場
那
誰輸誰就開始停損
然後
就打過了
所以這邊會進一個
679的空單
那
停損一樣是
這一根K棒的低點
因為
下去
這一根K棒就不用停損了
這個是一個700多口
也是非常多
所以這是一個
加679
然後停損是
所以它的
Risk是18
那
加18乘以2
是
然後
然後這邊就
這個地方
如果它疊破
這邊你要掛喔
要掛6
685的兩倍空單
那這邊是沒有打到
低點是689
就是沒有疊破
這根黑K沒有疊破
這根紅K啦
所以
沒有反向
然後
然後這邊
然後這邊就順利的
穿架
所以這邊又再賺了36點
然後
然後這邊一樣掛著一個
出價空單
然後這邊又重新
這個
爆打量
所以就掛
713的
這個
出價空單
好
然後這邊馬上就吃到了
713的出價空單
所以
這邊是713空
然後
停損不會是這根的高點
因為這根高點是
那+1的話是733
那
但是這邊
高點是734
你停損在733是非常不合理的事情
所以你的停損點會是735
這樣才是合理的
因為是創新高停損
然後
所以這邊是-713
然後停損735
然後這邊的這一根
因為這個也是爆打量嘛
所以如果他被掌過的話
是703掛兩倍的出價多單
然後馬上就掌過了
所以這邊是一個713的空單
被多空
空直接翻多
703的兩倍多單
然後
然後這邊也是持續追蹤他的低點
這邊是702
然後這邊改成706
就是
如果又觸到706的話
就又再
這邊是空單翻成多單
然後馬上又再翻成空單
所以這是一個713的空單
然後變成
翻成+703的多單
然後又再翻成-706的多單
那他的停損就是這一個地方
就是718
所以這是一個-706的空單
然後停損718
所以他的Risk是12
停利點就是682
好然後這邊順利疊下來
但是又彈回去
彈回有出價到70-706
那
因為這個停損不是在最低點
然後
這個就保本出場
就是又打回成...
就是疊下來之後又反彈回去打回成本價了
然後...
因為有倒過一倍的Risk
所以就...
就保本出場
然後這邊就...
重新是空手
然後這邊這個是...
如果漲過的話
會打一個6
5的多單
好
然後...
然後在這邊
123456789
好
大概...
快要10分鐘之後
進場一個6
95的多單
然後...
他的低點是674
所以...
這個...
Risk
是21
然後...
然後這邊有倒過21點
好
有倒過21點
但是...
沒有到...
沒有到那個...
呃...
停力的兩倍嘛
也要42點
所以...
這一單是...
這個...
呃...
就是...
6...
695的地方保本
然後在...
這一根...
爆大量的...
接近十字的...
K棒被疊破的地方是...
會重新空單進場
所以是...
692的空單進場
然後...
692的空單進場之後
這邊一樣要設定...
長過這個...
這個...
696+1
就是697的話就多單進場
那這邊又長過了
所以這個692的多單在...
697被翻成...
呃...空單被翻成多單
所以這邊是...
就是...
停損5點
然後...
然後這個...
呃...
這個697的空單
它的risk是...
呃...
12+2
10...
14...
14×2
然後...
697+28是...
所以停力點是725
然後...
這邊...
這邊就一直在725...
差...
一直差兩點
一直沒到725啊
這個等很久
一直沒到725
那這邊就是掛著
這邊是...
如果跌破這邊就是...
699翻兩倍的空單
或者是725停力
好...
然後就一直等...
等等等等...
等等...
好...
這邊真的等很久
我就一邊跟我朋友...
這個...
聊...
語音聊天
然後這邊...
725觸了一下
那有可能有人沒成交
但是後來這邊...
這個...
就是這邊...
這邊有人群組說沒成交啦
但是到這邊就大家都成交了
好...很好
然後這邊又出現一個大量的...
K棒
所以這是一個掛726的...
出價空單
然後...
好然後這個是真的...
真的...
蠻久之後
兩個禮拜以後~
誒...
這麼久嗎?
喔好...
然後這邊就...
疊破了...
7...
727...
所以是一個726的出價空單
那...
就不要最高點停損了
太遠了
所以就是...
這根K棒的高點
742...
那所以Risk是16
那所以是726-16*2
就是694停禮
然後這邊...
這邊是觸到694
那可能有人沒成交到這邊就...
就穿架了
那就確定大家都成交了
所以這邊...
這一單...
又成功了...
收下了32點
然後...
然後後面的成交量就...
都很低
所以...
後面就...
沒什麼好看了
好
到這邊是...
收盤
那這就是...
今天的...
不對
是昨天的...
復盤
然後...
然後這個是...
這個...
昨天我...
就是我晚上...
這個...
結束之後我會在群組打...
當天的夜盤復盤
那...
這一天的...
這個...
總損益就是...
打了16單
然後總共...
這個...
賺...
117點
那是有扣掉...
這個...
手續費跟稅的16點
就是...
原始是...
加一百三十幾點
然後扣掉16點的稅這樣子
好
所以這就是...
這個...
美國的...
眾議院議長裴伏器來台灣的...
這一天晚上...
我們...
這個...
當充...
短線交易者的一個...
實戰復盤
希望大家有學到很多東西
就這樣啦...
我要來打...
今天的盤了...